joining me now
the former democrat state senate leader
who's endorsing larry elder gloria
ramirez gloria it's an honor to have you
on this program tonight
i have to ask thank you thank you
um why was education the breaking point
for you
my mother had a sixth grade level of
education i earned a phd and ultimately
chaired the senate education committee
to me education is a civil rights issue
and especially in california with over
six million children in the public
school system i take a look at the
outcomes and we find that some seventy
percent of latino children cannot do
math at grade level standards it's about
80 percent for african-american youth
and that was before the pandemic and now
they're trying to teach our youth that
four you know that two plus two doesn't
even equal four to me i believe that
school choice is what breaks the chains
of poverty and i finally got tired of
waiting for governor after governor
legislature after legislature to do
something right for especially children
of color but really all children all
families in california that's why i
gravitated to support the recall and
especially larry elder you know school
choice broke the cycle for me and my
family but i got to ask you
what happens
if gavin newsom remains the governor
well again two what happens is we're
going to see same old same old
essentially sadly and i'm a democrat i
have personally seen the hostage taking
the political hostage taking in
sacramento i have seen personally
whether it's by the humongous campaign
contributions the outsized influence of
how policy is written basically no
budget gets decided without the input of
the cta the california teachers
association so what happens is basically
it's like groundhog day except when it
comes to our school children it's a very
serious negative effect as a democrat i
really am disappointed in a democratic
party that purports to stand for
the rights of minorities of working
class communities and yet it fails on
the most important issue for us
education so i think the schools will be
shut down again we're going to continue
to see the captive audience to special
interests that run the show in
sacramento gavin will be fine his kids
will continue to go to the private
school of his choice but six million
children overwhelmingly latino and
african-american children will basically
be condemned by zip code to failing
schools gloria you are a leading
democrat you're still a democrat
and i've always wondered this this one
question because we saw it in the white
house when cdc said it is safe for kids
to go back to school but then there was
an email that went out and the teachers
unions changed that and jinsaki the
press secretary said no actually it's
not right so what happens behind closed
doors
with the teachers union do they send
demands out and legislators are expected
to go along with it or they won't get
endorsements or they will fund their
opponents what happens
money talks
and the politicians walk that's really
what happens uh cta is the most powerful
political force in california it
contributes more to a political war
chest than oil pharmaceuticals
gas combined
and these are not your everyday teachers
in a classroom and we have seen fights
that have gone all the way to the
supreme court to try to break free of
those mandatory union jews that
basically pay for candidates and issues
that rank and file teachers don't
support so it really is the power of
money that basically has become a very
sour milk in reproducing inequality in
california and really much across the
nation as well and that's what this
recall to me was about a chance to break
this system and i found no stronger
voice than larry elder who actually has
survived that and is an eloquent speaker
on the need for school choice thank you
gloria i appreciate you joining the
program i know that the democratic
machine is going to be after you thank
you so much